in November 2nd plenary session the  Parliament is voting on the EU budget  for 2018 which focuses on job creation  security and managing migration  lawmakers vote on measures to encourage  the use of renewable energy they want to  promote self consumption renewable  energy communities and district heating  and cooling systems the implementation  of a European Disability strategy is up  the debate it aims to enable people with  disabilities to participate fully in  society without environmental or social  barriers lawmakers may veto legislation  to allow the use of phosphates in kebab  meat they argue that there is no proven  need